مشاهدينا الكرام نحن نتحدث عن المناطق
الشماليه والجنوبيه من قطاع غزه وفق ما
اعلنت كتابه القسام في مقاطع الفيديو التي
شاهدناها قبل قليل واذا ما بدانا بالمناطق
الشماليه فنتحدث عن موقعه الشجاعيه هذه
هذا المكان الذي لا يزال يشهد معارك عنيفه
مع قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والمقاومه
الفلسطينيه التي تضرب كما تقول وفق مقاطع
الفيديو التي شاهدناها طبعا قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي كانت قد دمرت مناطق واسعه من
الشجاعيه ولكنها تستهدف المناطق الشرقيه
وفي مقاطع الفيديو التي شاهدناها لاحظنا
حجم الدمار الكبير الذي يخرج من بينه
المقاتلون ليضربوا القوات الاسرائيليه
المتوغلة
القسام في الشجاعيه لذلك المقاومه عنيفه
وشرسه في الشجاعيه تسعى قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي للوصول الى قلب مدينه غزه او
البلده القديمه ب مدينه غزه من الجهه
الشرقيه من جهه الشجاعيه لذلك الضغط كبير
في منطقه الشجاعيه اذا ما انتقلنا الى
مناطق اخرى كانت قد اعلنت عنها كتائب
القسام اليوم اعلنت اليوم انها استهدفت
طبعا في الشجاعيه كان هناك استخدام كما
شاهدنا في الفيديو ل صاروخ جديد او مقذوف
جديد من نوع ار بي او اي وهو صاروخ او
مقذوف روسي الصنع ويستهدف التحصينات
بالروسي معناه قاذف الب ويستهدف الافراد
والتحصينات واخ واستخدمته كتاب القسام في
منطقه الشجاعيه صاروخ اخر استخدمته كتاب
القسام اليوم كان في المنطقه الشماليه من
مدينه غزه الشماليه الغربيه نتحدث عن
الصفطاوي اليوم حيث استخدمت كتاب القسام
للمره الاولى صاروخ سام 18 لاستهداف
الطيران المروحي الاسرائيلي الحربي في
سماء هذه المنطقه بالاضافه ال ايضا عمليات
استهداف للاليات والجنود الاسرائيليين
المتحصنين في منطقه الصفطاوي لماذا
الصفطاوي وقوات الاحتلال عندما توغلت من
المناطق الشماليه دخلت من جهه الصفطاوي
والشيخ رضوان ومنطقه النصر وصولا الى
الرمال ومستشفى الشفاء والان هي تحاول
الالتفاف من هذه الجهه باتجاه جباليا
البلد للدخول نحو مخيم الشجاعيه الذي لا
يزال يشهد معارك ضاريه لان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لم تستطع الاستحكام حتى هذه
اللحظه في مخيم جبالي لذلك هي تحاول
الدخول الى مخيم جباليا من الجهه الجنوبيه
كتاب القسام اليوم اعلنت بان منطقه جباليا
البلد هذه المنطقه شهدت معارك عنيفه
بطبيعه الحال هناك مخيم جبالي للاجئين
الفلسطينيين وجبالي البلد البلده القديمه
منطقه جبالي
البلد شهدت معارك عنيفه وخصوصا المنطقه
الغربيه من جباليه البلد اي اننا نتحدث عن
منطقه ما بين الشيخ رضوان وجباليا والنزله
في هذه المنطقه كان هناك معارك عنيفه وفق
ما اعلنت كتائب القص قسام اذا ما انتقلنا
الى المناطق الجنوبيه من قطاع غزه او
دعونا في المناطق الوسطى استهدافات عنيفه
للاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه لمناطق
البريج اليوم قصف عنيف على منطقه البريج
النصيرات المغازي المنطقه الوسطى بشكل عام
من قطاع غزه كان لها نصيب كبير من
الاستهدافات الاسرائيليه وايضا في الوقت
نفسه وكتائب القسام اعلنت انها استهدفت
الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
عندما نتحدث عن المنطقه الشرقيه فنحن
نتحدث عن حوالي من السياج الفاصل حوالي
كيلو و400 متر طبعا هذه المنطقه كلها من
شارع صلاح الدين الى الى السياج الفاصل
نتحدث عن حوالي ثلاثه كيلومترات وبالتالي
نحن نتحدث عن التوغل في هذه المنطقه
واستهداف مخيم البريج في هذه المنطقه
نتحدث عن هذه المساحه والمسافات التي تضرب
فيها كتائب القسام والمقاومه الفلسطينيه
الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه دعونا نذهب
سريعا الى المنطقه المنطقه الجنوبيه
ومقاطع الفيديو التي شاهدناها في المنطقه
الجنوبيه من مدينه غزه طبعا مدينه مدينه
خانيونس عفوا مدينه خانيونس القوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كانت قد توغلت من
الجهه الشرقيه لخان يونس من عبسان باتجاه
بن سهيلا من الجهه الشماليه الشرقيه من
جهه الزن باتجاه بن سهيلا استهدفت بن
سهيلا بشكل اساسي لان بن سهيلا تؤدي
بطبيعه الحال الى مدينه خان يونس في هذه
النقطه وهي المنطقه التي تريد قوات
الاحتلال الوصول اليها في الوقت نفسه دخل
خلت الاليات العسكريه من الجهه الشماليه
الغربيه من جهه مدينه حمد وجهه مناطق ما
بات يعرف بمحرر جوش قطي في المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه وتستهدف مدينه خانيونس
وفي هذه المنطقه تدور المعارك العنيفه
الان على اطراف مدينه خان يونس وهي
المشاهد التي شاهدناها كما اعلنت كتائب
القسام هذ